put him up that's right folks I am an
adult man talking about Star Wars
wearing a suit jacket a ring a necklace
a Star Wars curtain cape and a bill and
ted's shirt you too
there is another trailer for Star Wars I
didn't think there was gonna be another
trailer and I certainly didn't think I
was gonna watch one let alone talk about
one but I woke up this morning and I was
like all right Warcraft trailer oh my
god there's new Star Wars trailer budget
that point I feel like Star Wars is
sniping Warcraft every chance they get
if you didn't know Warcraft was supposed
to come out in December 18th and then
Star Wars got pushed to December 18th
and Warcraft was like damn it
all right well come out later the
Warcraft is like all right for Blizzcon
we're gonna have any warcraft trailer
and Star Wars is like here's another
Star Wars trailer the war rages on folks
but we nerds are happy because it's a
pretty good a nerdy day don't talk about
the Star Wars trailer because there was
enough new stuff for me be like oh my
gosh I like that all I'm talking about
that and this trailer starts out how
most of the Star Wars trailers start out
in the desert with Rey just talking a
little bb-8 ball head droid she's like
where do you come from what's up don't
she's like I I know about waiting I'm
waiting for my family I was like oh are
you Jane our solo I know JJ Abrams said
he's not gonna pull from the Timothy
Zahn Laura any of the extended lore that
came out before this movie but you got
to speculate I said in my last trailer
video I think her and kylo Ren are
linked one of the main reasons is if you
look at the poster her staff and his
lightsaber are perfectly parallel to
each other but she meets Finn and one of
the best shots I've seen in the trailers
yet they look and then these TIE
fighters are coming at them from the
sunset it looks like sunset riders but
with TIE fighters and funny enough when
kylo Ren's talking to the burned up
Darth Vader mask he says I will fulfill
our destiny but a lot of rumors around
as to whether or not kylo Ren is Luke
Skywalker I don't quite know about that
doesn't mean they can't fool us I just
find it interesting that he says I will
fulfill our destiny it's like it makes
you think he is Skywalker of some sort
or Jason's solo this trailer just does a
good job at mixing the fields of the
trailer we got a couple weeks ago with a
lot more action a lot of new stuff that
I like this cape is like sliding but it
looks kind of badass guy looks like
super stormtrooper so I'm gonna keep as
long as I can and among all the sweet
imagery it's what I'm loving about these
trailers you see shots in these trailers
where you're like yeah that's not Lucas
right there that is someone new we see
Chewbacca like I mean he detonates
something I'm like choo
you're so cool you were a badass we
already knew bookies were warriors but I
mean the dude just detonated a vibe
never seen Chuy detonate a bomb I don't
know what to say I like the fact that
I've now on screen seen Chuy detonate a
bomb and they've seen where kylo Ren
brings his wonky ass jagged lightsaber
down to Ray's phase that's just the most
menacing thing ever is having a sword
next to your face it really just shows
control you're in control of that person
in this situation but it's a lightsaber
it just feels like more because it's a
lightsaber looks like a lightsaber that
was built by someone who has no training
whatsoever in constructing a lightsaber
when these guys we have a new trailer
for Star Wars The Force awakens I loved
it I usually get scared about this time
I'm like are they gonna show too much
before the movie comes out this one
didn't actually show a lot it showed
more scenes but I loved it in the sense
that they showed more shots in the
trailer shots that will be in the movie
shots that make it look like Star Wars
is rejuvenated just life clarity the
Cape came off at the very end
I saw the new Star Wars Japanese trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you can use the force on this one
[Music]